the question of leadership is really
interesting because for for for most
businesses really at this point the loss
of control they fear is already in the
past right that that there was there was
a media environment in which almost any
message about IBM that was in the public
was created by IBM and then circulated
via press release or reported by a
newspaper or what have you and then of
course there was you know word of mouth
chatter on the street kinds of stuff but
that all operated at a level so much
smaller than anything a large company
could produce the biggest change in
leadership I think is that those days
are over and uh there's the the range of
choices leaders have about the
perception of their company has been
quite quite restricted because the
counter story will always get out as
well there's it's just it's just much
more of a dialogue in the public so so
the two great visions of of leadership
we have right the grand visionary or the
micro manager now seem to meet not to
work as well you know the Internet is
kind of compressed the range and
leadership has become instead a
combination of infusing a company with
whatever the core the core imperatives
are and making sure that the company
doesn't over balance too far in one
direction or another so Amazon to take
just just one example amazon has my
favorite corporate award ever in the
history of corporate awards they have an
award that you can only win as an
employee if you do something great and
you didn't ask permission first all
right the other words you can get if you
ask permission if you clear things with
your bosses but if you do something
really good and you just saw that it was
a possibility and you did it you've got
a special award for not having asked
permission and that's an example of
something that you know
to your friend your earlier point about
your friend lowers the amount of
internal communication required and also
sets a cultural norm for the business
that no amount of memos and mission
statements could possibly send and that
kind of leadership what what what what
Bezos does I think in terms of creating
a cultural climate where good ideas are
rewarded matters so much more than you
know either grand visionary or micro
manager in this in this environment